but in terms of like your size like is
it really hard on certain parts of your
body to be that big I think it's hard on
the heart so there's a couple things
that I start to feel it's um the lung
capacity feels like I just can't keep up
you know um like if I I did Sprints this
morning it's just amazing how quick I'm
like like really winded and it did
wasn't always like that but I'm trying
to get a lot of oxygen to a lot of
muscles but uh you know I weigh 240
pounds and I'm you know if I'm climbing
there's some hills out here where I am
where I'll I'll run these Hills if I'm
climbing up a hill it's a little bit
like doing lunges for 20 minutes
straight I mean throw for most people
throw 280 on your shoulders and do 20
minutes of lunges your muscles are going
to explode so I feel like when I'm
running I start to feel my muscles
aching just because it's like it's just
I'm pushing a lot of weight one one one
step at a time you know without without
breaking and you you know you feel that